israel is hoping this drilling ship will
help boost its offshore gas output
energy and power company aims to bring
the karish field online later this year
something long time enemy and neighbor
lebanon opposes officials say these are
contested waters and any development
will be considered a provocation and
hostile act
because for the israelis and for the is
for the us this is not in disputed zone
it is far away from the disputed zone
because for the israelis the lebanese
borders are where line 23 is located and
according to what lebanon had sent in
2011 to the u.n
in lebanon there is total confusion and
contradiction in statements and
impositions israel and lebanon have been
indirectly negotiating about the 860
square kilometer patch of sea but in
recent months lebanon expanded its claim
increasing the zone by 1430 square
meters which included the karish gas
field this led the talks to break down
lebanon has never legally laid claim to
the line 29 boundary president michelle
own didn't sign a decree to rectify a
map submitted to the united nations
which would have affected israel's
ability to move ahead with the
operations
hezbollah is the most powerful actor in
the country and has fought wars with
israel in the past a few weeks ago it
didn't just express opposition to
negotiations with israel over the
dispute its leader hassan nasrallah was
confident no international firm would
dare come to karish or anywhere else in
the disputed area if hezbollah issues a
clear and serious threat so far none has
been made
this is going to be a way for hezbollah
to gain as much as possible
leverage to
improve its position in government
formation and selection of the
forthcoming president so if hezbollah
for instance
looked the way around instead of
starting a new confrontation with israel
on the southern border the israeli navy
has been sent to protect the rig but
lebanon's leaders have called for a u.s
envoy to return so that the parties can
resume talking it's a sign of
de-escalation that appears to have been
the result of backdoor negotiations
senator al-jazeera beirut
let's get more on this we can speak to
nelly zibber he's a journalist and a
adjunct fellow of the washington
institute he joins us live now from tel
aviv
does israel have legal jurisdiction over
this particular piece of water if you
like
well in israeli mines they do
they they're on firm ground so to speak
in these naval waters
the israeli government has very clearly
said today and in recent days that this
is fully part of its exclusive economic
zone
its maritime waters and that it's not
part of the small
area in disputes with lebanon that has
been in mediation now for for several
months
how are these maritime borders
determined
well
initially it was u.n mediation and there
was an exchange of maps as your
correspondent alluded to uh but more
recently uh there has been u.n uh u.s
mediation rather between israel and
lebanon indirectly uh trying to come to
some kind of compromise over that
smaller part of the disputed
gas field and economic waters
there had seemed to be some progress
made at least last year with regard to
these talks but it seems
like domestic politics in lebanon
primarily the role of hezbollah
eventually
undermined these talks and put a stop to
them the hope now is that this this
latest uh spat and diplomatic escalation
will perhaps lead to renewed talks
that's at least what the israeli
government is calling for
earlier this morning
what's at stake here for israel
well i think what the stake for israel
is this is would be the third offshore
natural gas field to come online so
obviously that helps with israel's own
energy security and big picture uh
israel is looking to export
additional natural gas uh to europe
whether through liquefied form or
through uh in future a pipeline uh so in
terms of israel the stakes are primarily
i think economic uh for lebanon though
uh i think the stakes are are much
higher we all know that it's going
through a major energy crisis an
economic crisis if not a political
crisis and that any kind of natural gas
field that comes online may be able to
uh ameliorate those domestic problems
inside lebanon is that the hope
israeli media reporting that the navy is
now deploying a version of its iron dome
anti-missile system onto that disputed
sea border do you think israel could go
to war over this
no i don't believe so the deployment of
iron dome in its naval format and other
security measures are not new and not
unique to this
specific
gas rig and this specific natural gas
offshore field these are precautions
that have been taken now for for several
years
to safeguard what israel will be used as
a strategic asset
offshore
and i don't believe
lebanon despite the rhetoric coming out
of beirut
and hezbollah in particular will go to
war over natural gas
there are other areas of dispute between
israel and hezbollah primarily that
could touch off a war i don't believe
natural gas is one of them okay neri
ziba journalist and adjunct fellow at
the washington institute thank you